bloodborne chalice dungeons are an
optional adventure but when you need a
partake in the dungeons offer new
challenges traps enemies and treasure
hunting you'll earn some nice rewards if
you're willing to fight and explore your
way through these dungeons three big
items you can receive that you can get
in the chalice dungeons are the bone ash
armor set a madman's armor set and the
beasts claws in addition to these three
items you can also get higher-level gems
ruins high-level enchanting materials
and alternate versions of pre-existing
weapons that have different blood gem
slots in order to get the bone ash armor
set you'll have to get through the
central the Marion labyrinth you'll need
to venture past the first layer of the
dungeon and into layer two once you've
arrived in layer two make your way to
the boss and defeat the keeper of the
old Lords who's wearing the armor you
want to acquire after defeating the
keeper of the old Lords you now have the
ability to buy this armor from the
insight store the armor notably has high
physical and fire resists to require the
madman armor set you'll need to acquire
the hint or tuned chalice which is in
the central Tamarian chalice dungeon in
a coffin found on layer 2 once you've
acquired the hinter tomb chalice make
your way through it and acquire the
lower hinter tomb chalice from the last
boss in that dungeon once you've gotten
the lower hinter tomb chalice dungeon
you'll need to fight your way through
until you get to the second layers boss
the boss is the Forgotten madman and
again he's wearing the armor you want to
acquire be careful though as when the
forgotten man man gets to about 50%
health his escort will come to his aid
so now you'll have to deal with two
hunters instead of just one after
defeating them you now have the ability
to buy the madman's armor in the insight
store the madman's armor set seems to
have good arcane bolt and fire resist if
you want to unleash your beast your
instincts you'll need to find the beasts
claws the beasts claws will be found in
a coffin in the alien war in chalice
dungeon on layer 2 the claws are unique
because when you use its alternate form
you're not only gaining a giant beasts
hand as part of the weapon you'll also
be emitting a yellow haze from your body
as well the beasts claws basically give
you the buff you get
a two-piece pellet except it's
never-ending the interesting thing about
the beast clause is that as you do
damage you'll start filling a meter up
that appears to have a beasts head
insignia next to it you'll gain a fair
bit of damage if you can continue to
keep that meter up I gained about
roughly a hundred fifty physical damage
when my meter was up I've gotten the
meter to a hundred percent in a semi
unrealistic situation but it ended up
not doing anything special
so unless I'm missing an item in the
game there isn't really an actual
transformation outside of what we're
already seeing at the time I was also
using the to be streams you can acquire
in the game as well we'll have to see
with further investigation if you can
become a beast or not I've also heard
lowering your insight helps build the
meter faster chalice dungeons also offer
high level gems that you can find that
you can't find in the story portion as
well as alternate weapons for you to
hunt for you can get a lost or uncanny
version of a pre-existing weapon which
has the same base damage but has
different gem slots for you to customize
and maximize your damage with some of
the higher tiered curse gems are
interesting because you gain tremendous
offensive power but at the cost of
something else you'll also have the
chance to acquire blood rocks from the
chalice dungeons which will give you the
ability to a chant your weapon two plus
ten there's only one blood rock in the
story portion that I know so unless
you're playing new game+ chalice
dungeons will be the place for you to
get additional blood rocks chalice
dungeons are a unique experience that I
would say everyone has to try if you
happen to have skipped them and our
higher level the first view will be
cakewalk but you'll need to do them in
order to get higher level chalices also
in order to get the chalice dungeons
with more depth and difficulty you'll
have to defeat side bosses in the story
mode including Amidala for the alien
Lauren chalice and a breda the daughter
of the cosmos for the is chalice
however I implore you to try to get to
the final through Marion dungeon as it
has in my opinion one of the most
interesting boss fights in the game also
it's pretty creepy
stay tuned at Gamescom for more
blood-borne coverage
you